le conseil constitutionnel la politique
c'est comme un grand jeu de société le
but c'est d'exercer le pouvoir de
fabriquer des lois et de faire vivre la
démocratie
le conseil constitutionnel c'est
l'institution qui arbitre ce grand jeu
il est composée de neuf juges trois sont
nommés par le président de la république
3 par le président du sénat et trois par
le président de l'assemblée nationale
il faut que ce soit des personnalités
cas les endroits et très respectée par
l'ensemble de la classe politique
ces arbitres ont donc comme première
fonction de contrôler les élections
il détermine si les joueurs ont été bien
sélectionner le conseil proclame les
résultats de l'élection présidentielle
il est censé également vérifier que tout
s'est bien passé et que personne n'a
triché il regarde par exemple qu'un
patron d'une grande entreprise n'a pas
donné de l'argent en dos à un candidat
pour que celui ci le favorise
en retour après son élection il étudie
aussi les recours après les élections
parlementaires ou locales quand il ya
contestation
à chaque élection et surtout si le
résultat est serré il y a toujours une
poignée de scrutin qui sont annulés par
exemple il est interdit de parler de la
vie privée d'un adversaire ou de
dépasser le plafond de dépenses autorisé
pour mener campagne
l'autre mission du conseil
constitutionnel c'est de vérifier la
conformité à la constitution des lois
votées par le parlement la loi votée
traite elle vraiment d'un sujet qui
nécessite une loi c'est souvent la
question qui est posée au conseil
parce qu'en france tout ne peut pas être
fait par une loi un texte législatif
par exemple la loi peut prévoir que l'on
réduise la vitesse sur les routes mais
c'est un décret est donc le gouvernement
qui doit fixer la vitesse autorisée la
loi doit surtout respecter les grands
principes d'égalité de liberté qui se
trouve aussi dans le préambule de la
constitution c'est le général de gaulle
qui a institué le conseil
constitutionnel en 1958 mais son but à
lui ce n'était pas tellement d'en faire
un arbitre c'était plutôt d'en faire une
institution qui vérifierait que le
parlement est donc la loi ne soit pas
trop puissant par rapport au
gouvernement
le décret au début il n'y avait que la
majorité qui pouvaient saisir le conseil
constitutionnel
larbitre était donc partial depuis 1974
l'opposition peut aussi demander au
conseil de vérifier la
constitutionnalité des lois
du coup depuis cette date presque toutes
les lois sont examinés par ce que l'on
appelle aussi les sages
depuis 2010 il existe même une façon
pour les citoyens après un procès au
cours duquel ils estiment que leurs
droits constitutionnels n'ont pas été
respectés de saisir les sages
ça s'appelle la qpc question prioritaire
de constitutionnalité maintenant après
plus de 50 ans d'existence et de
réformes
on peut dire que le conseil
constitutionnel est un arbitre impartial
et complet pour le grand jeu de la
politique française